you know i'm really not anti-company i'm
anti the business of how much
they're
taking on it was it easy for you to
break away like did you just fulfill
your contractual obligations or did you
ask to leave i asked to leave and it's
and
it's and it was it was easy to break
away because like i said the people
there
like i'm like we have a good
relationship like i love them they love
me and it was always easy to work it was
never like static like i've never had
like a book the label moment i never did
that because they're people they're
people doing their jobs you know right
that's it they're really just people
doing their jobs just the the business
of it wasn't right so i'm like yo
you know and by the way my song was so
massive that my [ __ ] advance checks
are crazy
so
do y'all really want to do you want me
to turn another album in you want me to
turn me another album in you cut me this
fat ass check like what do you want to
do you know what i mean because
and i was also kind of like
making lo-fi music at the time yeah like
probably like like look don't want this
no-fi album or what yeah nah nah we
don't actually and it's cool because i
kind of want to move on too so it's like
it's love you know it was good it was it
was actually really seamless really easy
that's dope man yeah well the albums
i've heard horror stories